the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
as you all know i have been making
videos on every chapter in the
song of ice and fire book series like i
have said before
i know many of you have still not read
them so i thought this would be a great
way for you to find out exactly what
happens in the books
as great as the show was in the early
seasons there was still a lot of very
interesting details left out now you
will know why some of us believe the
books are so much better than the show
in this video i will be discussing what
happens in ned stark's very first
chapter
once again this is another chapter that
is just loaded with information
not only does ned's first chapter shed
some light on certain historical events
but it also foreshadows many different
things that will happen in the future
as i have said before the first book
game of thrones has a lot of information
that may reveal how this entire
series will end ned stark's chapter is a
great example of this
we also get some more insight into ned
and robert's relationship
now i did go over some of this during
lady catlin's chapter
but now you will see them interacting
face to face
what makes this even more interesting is
that we are inside ned stark's head
during all of this
so we will know exactly what he thinks
or how he feels whenever something
significant
is mentioned now i will say the first
few minutes of this chapter won't be
extremely exciting
but just wait until we go into the
crypts beneath winterfell
now we will enter the mind of ned stark
as we see the events
unfold through his eyes shall we begin
at the beginning of the chapter we see
the arrival of king robert of house
baratheon
this is an incredible opening scene
because we will never see
all of these amazing characters in the
same location together again
when the gates of winterfell open up
hundreds of bannermen and knights
sworn swords and free riders arrive with
robert baratheon
like we saw in the show this is also
when we meet sir jamie lannister
who has hair as bright as beaten gold
and sandor clegane with his burned face
right beside him was everyone's favorite
character joffrey
and behind them was a stunted little man
who was none other than tyrion lannister
when robert arrives through the gates of
winterfell ned thinks about how he
almost seems like a stranger
it has been so many years since they
have seen each other robert says
ned hasn't changed at all ned wishes he
could say the same thing
he thinks about the old robert from 15
years ago
the man who he helped take the iron
throne back then
when robert was still the lord of
storm's end he had been clean-shaven
clear-eyed and muscled like a maiden's
fantasy
now you would never know this from the
show but the robert from the books is
six and a half feet tall
the man is an absolute giant back then
he had the strength of a giant too
robert's weapon of choice was a spiked
iron warhammer that ned could barely
lift now think about that for a second
even when ned stark would use both of
his hands
he could barely lift robert's warhammer
but robert could swing and kill while
only using one hand
the man was a straight up savage this
isn't the same robber that ned sees now
he now has the weight to match his
height and let's face it
robert baratheon is washed up by the
time we meet him
this makes ned think about the last time
he saw robert which was 9 years ago
during the greyjoy rebellion
this was when theon's father baylon
greyjoy tried to break away from the
seven kingdoms to secure independence
for the iron islands and restore the old
way
which was lost almost 300 years ago
during aegon's conquest
robert and ned had joined their forces
and together
they crushed the greyjoy rebellion not
only was baylon greyjoy stopped
but robert also made him bend that knee
which he did
just to make sure baylon never rose up
again ned stark took his last remaining
heir
theon greyjoy back to winterfell to live
with him and his family
so as you can see robert and ned worked
very well together
now they obviously had some help but
they were able to secure the iron throne
for robert
by defeating house targaryen and
whenever a house tried to rise up
against them
they would beat them back into
submission as well those were the good
old days
now robert was overweight and looking
old he has a big stomach
and a big beard to hide his double chin
ned also notices he has dark circles
under his eyes
it's obvious that robert has become very
lazy he has been neglecting
all of his duties as the king all he
wants to do is get drunk and have fun
i mean who doesn't want to do that every
now and then but this worries ned
this isn't the same robert he has known
for all these years
if robert wasn't the king i swear he
would have became the neighborhood bum
that sits in front of the liquor store
all day drinking 40s out of a brown bag
however it doesn't really matter what
ned thinks
because robert is his king not only just
his friend
now just like we saw on the show ned
says your grace
winterfell is yours this is also the
same thing we heard sansa say when
daenerys first arrived in winterfell
right after ned says this is when cersei
lannister and her children step out of
the carriage
into the courtyard now the carriage
cersei wrote in during the show
is nothing like the one she wrote in
during her arrival at winterfell
their wheelhouse in the books is a
double-decker carriage that has to be
driven by
40 heavy horses this thing is so massive
it's not able to fit through
winterfell's main gate and i must say
the lannisters of house kardashian sure
do know how to ride in style
then we go through the formalities of
everyone greeting everyone
same as we saw on the show this is
followed up by robert
asking ned to take him down to see
lyanna it says ned loves him for this
even after all these years robert still
remembers her
and you would think that ned already
knows how much lyanna's death affected
him
robert would never forget about lyanna
later in this chapter
ned even thinks about how robert loved
her more than he did
they went down to the crypt together ned
in this king he scarcely recognized
robert begins to talk about his journey
north and how empty all the lands were
he wonders where is everyone ned says
they were likely too shy to come out
kings are hardly ever seen in the north
robert snorted
more likely they were hiding under the
snow now if you are reading this very
carefully
you would have noticed that this was a
hidden reference to jon snow
actually being the king of the seven
kingdoms ned said
kings are a rare sight in the north but
robert says
more likely they were hiding under the
snow i believe this is a hidden message
from george rr martin
letting us know there is a king in the
north who is hiding under the snow
as in the name snow it's no coincidence
we are given this big clue
right as ned and robert are about to go
see jon snow's real mother
lyanna ned will soon be thinking about
the promise he made to lyanna
this is of course when ned hides jon's
identity by saying he is his son
and giving him the best name snow the
way george snuck this line in there is
genius
these little hidden messages are
scattered throughout all the books
so as ned and robert are descending
further and further into the crypts of
winterfell
they talk about how bad the winters are
in the north ned says
the winters are hard but the starks will
endure we always have
i believe this is also some
foreshadowing for how the books will end
this may have even been confirmed in the
game of thrones television show
a song of ice and fire is a generational
saga where we follow the lives of many
different characters
but it's mostly the children in this
story who we will follow until the very
end
at the beginning we follow ned stark who
seems to be the main character of the
series
but then he dies and then his wife and
then his oldest son
who we believed would go on to avenge
his father's death
right when it seems like all hope is
lost for house stark
winter finally comes and this is where
the starks shine brightest
we saw how things ended for how stark in
the show
bran stark became the king of westeros
sansa stark became the queen of the
north
arya stark went to go see what was west
of westeros
and jon snow went into the far north
where he basically became the king
beyond the wall
the ending may have been bittersweet but
the starks did get some big victories in
the end
now i know we're talking about the books
here but this may happen in the books as
well
george r martin has said the song of ice
and fire series will consist of seven
books
as of right now we are waiting for book
number six
the winds of winter some of you might
not know this but book number seven was
originally going to be called
a time for wolves george r martin did
eventually change the name
to a dream of spring but his original
title may have given us a glimpse into
the future
that's why i think ned was foreshadowing
what would happen to house stark when he
said
the starks will endure the winter as
they always have
alright so as they are walking to
lyanna's statue robert begins to sell
ned
on the idea of coming south with him
robert says
you need a taste of the summer before it
flees and robert describes how amazing
things are in the south
he tells ned about how there are fields
of golden roses as far as the eyes can
see
there are fruits so right they instantly
explode in your mouth
the summer wines are so cheap and so
good that you can get drunk
just by breathing in the air there are
flowers everywhere
and the markets are loaded with food and
the girls ned
oh god the girls i swear women lose all
modesty in the heat
they swim naked in the river right below
the castle
even when they do wear clothes it's so
hot outside their clothes stick to their
skin
and they might as well be naked anyway i
mean robert is really selling this to
ned
robert knows he is about to ask ned to
come south with him to be his hand of
the king
he knows ned will not want to leave his
home and his family so easily so he
makes it sound like it will be the
greatest experience he can ever have
for a brief moment robert becomes a
salesman and he does everything he can
to set his hooks and net
but robert should know better than this
the honorable ned stark does not get
excited
over the thought of young hot women
running around naked in the streets
oh no no no no no that's not the ned we
know and love
in fact ned even thinks about this and
this may be seen as more evidence that
ned is not actually jon snow's father
right after robert tells ned about all
these amazing things in the south
ned thinks to himself robert had always
been a man of big appetites
a man who knew how to take his pleasures
dead ned thinks
that was not a charge anyone could lay
at the door of eddard stark
we are led to believe ned stark cheated
on his wife catelyn
which resulted in him having a bastard
child jon snow
however when robert baratheon tells ned
about all the different women in the
south running around naked
ned doesn't even flinch and that's
because ned would never cheat on his
wife
when we are inside ned's head we are
getting his honest thoughts
he doesn't have to lie to himself to
save jon he only has to do that in front
of everyone else
ned knows the truth but george rr martin
can't allow ned to have those exact
thoughts this early in the story or it
would ruin the big reveal later
now let's move on to what the chapter
says next i believe this is where we get
even more foreshadowing
this is where we get some hints that
those statues in the crypts of
winterfell
may rise from the dead so to speak as
robert and ned descend deeper and deeper
into the crypts
the statues almost seem to come alive as
their shadows run away from the light
from their lantern
as the flickering light from their
lantern shines on the stone statues
the shadows seem to move around ned
thinks about how the statues eyes seem
to follow them as they walk in front of
them
there are so many references to this in
this one scene alone
we saw what happened in the crypts
during season 8 when the night king and
his army of the dead were in winterfell
i think this is something dan and dave
most likely got from george rr martin
as you can see it looks as if he has
been foreshadowing this from the very
beginning of the books
and i happen to think there is something
much darker down below winterfell
i have made videos about this before and
i even mentioned it in one of my most
recent videos where i went over some of
the connections between house stark and
the white walkers
i happen to think there may be a night's
king or a knight's queen
buried down in the crypts below
winterfell many of the statues down here
are the old kings of winter
and i think the night king could be seen
as the ultimate king of winter
when the white walkers came during the
long night i think this is the exact
location where winter fell
hence the name of the stark's castle not
to mention their house words or winter
is coming
all these references are a reminder of
what happened here roughly 8 000 years
ago
something is down there in the crypts
just waiting to rise from the dead
whenever we hear about the white walkers
in the books they are mostly described
as shadows moving through the woods
as robert and ned are walking down here
ned thinks about how the statues seem to
be coming alive
as their shadows move around again and
again now what i find to be very
interesting is what it says next
as robert and ned are walking to leona's
statue ned thinks about how the iron
long swords are laid across the laps of
each who had been lord of winterfell
to keep the vengeful spirits in their
crips but ned also thinks about how
these iron long swords are starting to
rust away
and this makes him very worried he is
worried that these vengeful spirits will
be able to escape from their crips
now why would he be worried about that
if these are his own family members
why would he be so afraid of them i
think it's because something else is
down here
and although ned doesn't know exactly
what it is deep down he's afraid of what
it could be
the original night's king was the 13th
lord commander at the night ford on the
wall
he married a woman that could only be
described as a female white walker
they were married for 13 years and
during that whole time
they were sacrificing children to the
white walkers beyond the wall
however the night king's brother who was
the stark in winterfell
joined his forces with the king beyond
the wall and together
they were able to defeat the night's
king and his corpse queen
i think the stark in winterfell brought
the night's king back to winterfell
since they were brothers and locked him
up in the crips beneath the castle
after all this is where the starks do
bury their dead
i think there is even a chance that the
knights queen was locked up down there
as well
this is why they started laying iron
longswords across the laps of the
statues
to keep the vengeful spirits within the
crips old nan even tells us
there are a few things the white walkers
hate she says one of those things just
so happens to be iron
but now these iron long swords are
rusting away in one day
these spirits may rise again now i'm
sure most of you have seen my most
recent video where i went over all of
this so i won't do it here again
but just try to remember some of these
details and some of these references
because i will mention them in some of
my other chapter videos whenever more
evidence is revealed
i think this is why there are so many
references to shadows moving around in
the crips
not only will they come alive like they
did in season 80 game of thrones
but i think there will also be a leader
down here as well like one of the
original knights kings
who was a stark alright now let's move
on ned stopped at the last
and lifted his oil lantern the crips
continued on into the darkness ahead of
them
but beyond them the tombs were empty and
unsealed
black holes waiting for their dead
waiting for him and his children
ned did not like to think of that right
here he told his king
robert nodded silently knelt and bowed
his head
there were three statues side by side
lord rickard stark
ned's father had a long stern face the
stone mason had known him well
on either sides of him were his children
brandon stark had been 20 when he died
strangled by the order of the mad king
aerys targaryen
only a few short days before he was the
wed catelyn talley of riverrun
his father had been forced to watch him
die lyanna had only been 16
when she died ned had loved her with all
his heart
robert had loved her even more she was
to have been his bride
she was more beautiful than that robert
said after a silence
his eyes lingered only on his face as if
he could will her back to life
so it's obvious that robert was greatly
affected by the death of lyanna
and i do wonder if lyanna had lived and
married robert
would he have became the absolute mess
that he is now i forget the exact line
in the show
but robert said something along the
lines of when leona died
it left a hole in his heart that not
even the seven kingdoms could fill
now maybe this is just a credit to the
acting during that scene
but i did believe robert when he said
that but as we all know
lyanna did not love robert running off
with rhaegar targaryen was very
irresponsible considering what it led to
however i don't blame her for wanting to
be with the one she actually loved
if only they would have done it the
right way but then we would not have
this amazing story so i suppose it had
to happen that way
then ned reminds robert i was with her
when she died
she wanted to come home to rest beside
her father and brandon
he could still hear her at times promise
me she had cried
in a room that smelled of blood and
roses promise me ned
the fever had taken her strength and her
voice had been faint as a whisper
but when he gave her his word the fear
had gone out of his sister's eyes
ned remembered the way she had smiled
then how tightly her fingers clutched
his as she gave up hold on her life
after that he remembered nothing now i
don't think i need to dive too deep into
this
i believe what we saw in the show is
more or less what we will see in the
books
right before lyanna died she gave ned
her son to keep as his own
and i think there is more than enough
evidence in the books to show that jon
snow is the son of rhaegar targaryen
and lyanna stark i may even release a
video where i show all the book evidence
i have found that shows jon snow as the
next in line for the iron throne
alright so then robert says i vowed to
kill rhaegar for what he did to her
you did ned reminds him only once
robert said bitterly they had come
together at the fort of the trident
while the battle crashed around them
robert with his warhammer in his great
antlered helm
the targaryen prince armored all in
black on his breastplate was the
three-headed dragon of his house
wrought all in rubies that flash like
fire in the sunlight
the waters of the trident ran red around
the hooves other destruyers as they
circled and clashed
again and again until at last a crushing
blow from robert's hammer
stove in the dragon and the chest
beneath it when ned had finally come on
the scene
rhaegar lay dead in the stream while men
of both army scrambled into swirling
waters for rubies knock free of his
armor
in my dreams i kill him every night
robert admitted
a thousand deaths will still be less
than he deserves
there was nothing ned could say to that
this chapter is just loaded with so much
information
as i said before it's easily one of my
favorite in a game of thrones
you can see that robert may have just as
much hatred for rhaegar
as he does love for lyanna this one
event
essentially led to the current story we
know and love today
rhaegar and lyanna running off together
is what led to so many things happening
like the birth of jon snow robert
killing rhaegar and defeating his army
brandon stark and his father getting
killed which led to ned getting
winterfell
and marrying catelyn which led to them
having all their children
rhaegar's defeat also led to the sack of
king's landing
which led to jaime killing the mad king
john aaron helping robert and ned during
this is what led to robert naming him
his hand of the king and then his death
led to robert coming to winterfell
to ask ned to be his new hand of the
king and so on and so forth
as ned and robert leave the crypts they
begin to speak about jon aaron's death
robert doesn't know what to make of it
he has never seen a man sickened so
quickly
one day he's fine and you think he will
live forever
and then a fortnight later he's dead the
sickness was like a fire in his gut
and it burned right through him you have
to remember robert and ned
loved john aaron like a father they grew
up together at the erie which is one of
the reasons why ned and robert
are more like brothers than friends now
one thing we do not see in the show is
what
robert intended to do with john aaron's
son the little sickly robert aaron who
is named after robert baratheon i might
add
in the books robert baratheon wanted
liza and john's son to be fostered at
casterly rock
with tywin lannister robert said jon has
no brothers and no other sons
was i supposed to leave him to be raised
by woman but we all know how protective
liza is over her sweet robin
she wasn't about to allow robert to send
him to live with tywin lannister
so she left king's landing in the middle
of the night and this made cersei
lannister furious
this was like a slap in the face because
letting sweet robin foster at casterly
rock
should have been seen as a great honor
now ned doesn't say it out loud
but he thinks liza may have done the
right thing he would not want his son
fostered with the lannisters either
ned offers robert to allow him to take
sweet robin as
his ward if he would allow it ned thinks
liza would allow that considering he is
married to her sister
however robert declines that offer from
ned
he said it's too late lord tywin already
agreed to take him
fostering the boy anywhere else would be
seen as a grievous affront to him
and i love what ned says next he says i
have more concern for my nephew's
welfare
than i do for lannister pride robert
says well
that is because you do not sleep with a
lannister this makes robert laugh
and as i said in my catlin chapter video
ned has no respect for house lannister
he still hasn't forgiven them for their
lack of effort during robert's rebellion
while everyone else was fighting tywin
lannister set at casterly rock
and waited until he knew what side would
win it wasn't until rhaegar and his army
fell
that he decided he would declare for
house baratheon
my father won the real war he killed
prince rhaegar
he took the crown while you hid on a
costly rock
that's when he sacked king's landing so
as you can see
ned does not care about hurting their
feelings if the lannisters see ned
fostering robin as a slap in the face
then so be it i mean what are they going
to do about it anyway
so now we're at the moment where robert
wants to know if ned will become his new
hand of the king
robert says these are difficult times
ned i need good men around me
men like john aaron those years we spent
in the eerie
gods those were good years ned i want
you at my side again
i want you down in king's landing not up
here at the end of the world
where you are no use to anybody you are
the only one my old friend
robert smiled lord eddard stark i would
name you the hand of the king
this did not surprise ned why else would
robert come all this way
the hand of the king was the second most
powerful man in the seven kingdoms
he spoke with the king's voice commanded
the king's armies
and drafted the king's laws at times he
even set upon the iron throne to
dispense the king's justice
when the king was absent or sick robert
was offering him a responsibility
as large as the realm itself but it was
the last thing ned wanted
no matter how amazing robert made the
south sound ned did not want to leave
winterfell
now robert tries to lighten the mood by
laughing but ned doesn't want to hear it
robert says you might at least humor me
with a smile
come south with me and i will teach you
how to laugh again
if lyanna had lived we would have been
brothers bound by blood
not just affection well it's not too
late
i have a son you have a daughter my joff
and your sansa shall join our houses as
lyanna and i
might have once have done this offer
does surprise ned
ned says sansa is only 11 years old and
robert says
old enough for a betrothal the marriage
can wait a few years
the king smiled now stand up and say yes
nothing would give me greater pleasure
your grace now we all know this is a lie
ned doesn't want to be handed the king
and he surely doesn't want sansa to
marry joffrey
but robert is his king ned says
these honors are all so unexpected may i
have some time to consider
i need to tell my wife robert says yes
yes of course
sleep on it if you must but do hurry i
am not a very patient man
the chapter ends as it says for a moment
eddard stark was filled with a terrible
sense of foreboding
this was his place here in the north he
looked the stone figures all around them
breathed in the chill silence of the
crypt he could feel the eyes of the dead
they were all listening he knew and
winter was coming
as you can see the chapter ends with us
getting another reference to the statues
watching and listening
right before ned thinks about winter
coming i think this is just another
example of the stark's connection to the
white walkers and how the statues below
their castle
may have vengeful spirits waiting to
rise up again
now you see why this is such a great
chapter it is loaded with so much
information
not only does it fill us in on some of
the amazing backstory like the history
between robert
rhaegar and lyanna but also the
foreshadowing of future events
like how how stark's story may end let
me know what you thought about this
chapter
do you think i'm misreading some of this
stuff or do you have something you want
to add
i would love to see what you have to say
i want to thank everyone for watching
the video
especially for those of you that made it
all the way until the end
i hope you all have a great day i will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you